medieval legends have a way of standing
the test of time from arthurian
literature to monty python and the holy
grail the legend of the black knight has
managed to survive in countless forms
throughout the centuries typically
portrayed as a villainous mysterious
character the black knight often masks
their identity and swears fealty to no
lord or lady like other knights do under
the shroud of anonymity a black knight
will conduct many a foul deed usually
riding on the back of a shadowy steed
and ultimately defeated by their polar
opposite a righteous white knight sworn
to do good a tale as old as time these
two nights of light and dark are the
embodiment of the eternal moral struggle
between good and evil with the stock
character of the black knight commonly
being associated with death and darkness
these aren't just legends of course or
are they it has been said that every
legend is rooted somewhere in truth
while the black knight has always been a
metaphorical figure a personification of
the notion of evil could there be a real
night clad in shadow that first inspired
the myth perhaps it's time you're
acquainted with scp-5151
which might just be the original black
knight himself as the name suggests
scp-5151 is a humanoid male figure who
is originally from the medieval era he
sports chainmail armor specifically a
type called a hauberg which is chainmail
that forms a full coat or tunic and he
also wears a laurel wreath around his
head he often refers to himself as the
black knight although he also claims to
have been known by other names and
titles throughout history according to
observations made by the scp foundation
the night never requires food water or
rest in order to survive although he has
been seen to eat and drink purely for
the enjoyment of it even though he
appears to wear armor and clothing
beneath every aspect of
scp-5151's clothing and his body share
the same anomalous properties every part
of him his armor his garments and his
longsword can phase through surfaces and
objects as if the knight was incorporeal
scp-5151 also appears to be able to
alter his physical properties at will
either becoming solid or more ghost-like
when he so chooses to as you can
probably imagine the foundation has
found it somewhat difficult to contain
the black knight thanks to these
abilities
scp-5151 also possesses an extraordinary
method of attack when confronted with a
target the knight will deem whether the
person is either worthy or dishonorable
though the criteria he is judging by
seems to be his own mysterious standards
should
scp-5151 find someone to be dishonorable
he will stab them directly through their
aorta with his longsword rather than
merely dispatch them though the black
knight will then proceed to drain every
drop of blood from his target's body
until they are little more than a dry
husk this was first witnessed during the
foundation's preliminary encounter with
scp-51
alerted to reports of vigilantism taking
place across a number of french
provinces the scp foundation followed
this lead to find a trail of bodies
across el sauce lorraine champagne and
orleanae the scp foundation dispatched
one of their many mobile task forces mtf
pi-1 also known under the code name city
slickers to look into the series of
murders what they soon found was that
these slain victims were anything but
innocent being guilty of multiple
murders themselves as well as the
abduction and trafficking of 18 children
from a french orphanage during their
investigation mobile task force agents
discovered the bodies of these criminals
had been killed by exsanguination the
process of extracting all the blood from
their bodies the victims possessed
matching stab wounds that pierced their
aortas but forensic analysis uncovered
no traces of blood appearing anywhere on
their clothing acting quickly the city
slickers apprehended another man who had
been involved in the same criminal
activities as the other two victims in
the hopes of drawing the killer out into
the open by using the trafficker as bait
a plan which as it turned out would
bring scp-5151
right to them while the mobile task
force were transporting the surviving
trafficker their vehicles were halted by
figures standing directly in their path
as the city slickers hit their brakes
scp-5151
began to slowly approach them ignoring
the agent's warning not to step any
closer one operative opened fire on the
approaching entity but the conventional
arms fire had no effect on the night
with the bullets passing right through
his intangible form the foundation mtf
agents instead tried to restrain
scp-5151
only to find that they could not
physically grab him their hands simply
passing through the black knight's body
reaching his target as cp 5151
dispatched of the remaining criminal in
the same way he had killed the previous
two by stabbing his longsword directly
into the trafficker's aorta and rapidly
draining the blood from him then the
black knight turned on the operatives
that had shot at him lunging for the
foundation agent and finishing him in
the exact same way as his other victims
immediately after killing the mobile
task force agent
scp-5151 seemed to surrender sheathing
his weapon and raising his hands in
submission before offering a greeting to
the remaining members of mtf pie one
brave fellows do not worry about him i
disposed of him as i have with others of
his lot loyalty is a virtue and the lack
of it will lead to the death of chivalry
my presence is a testament that chivalry
will never die with this being said i
understand you have been searching for
me pray tell what you might need of me
the mtf agents were not about to engage
in a parlay with a ghostly knight and
they contacted command at scp foundation
site 06-3
the site director in turn dispatched dr
sylvan moreau the senior researcher at
site 06-3 to conduct an on-site
interview with scp-5151
which took place on the roadside where
the knight had confronted the mobile
task force interestingly not only did
scp-5151 seem to engage dr moreau with
respect and friendly candor but he also
appeared to be fluent in french which
the doctor conducted the interview in as
they exchanged greetings the knight was
complained with the questions posed to
him apparently respectful of mero's
position as a doctor when asked
scp-5151 explained that he had attacked
the foundation agent who shot at him
because he deemed this individual to be
worth less than the ground he stood upon
moreau asked for further clarity on how
scp-5151 determined worthiness to which
the black knight replied by quoting
escalus an ancient greek playwright
often known as the father of greek
tragedy
scp-5151 claimed there is no disease
that i spit on more than treachery and
even claimed to know escalus personally
as a good man over the course of their
conversation dr moreau was able to
convince
scp-5151 to submit to containment with
the foundation however the knight made
specific requests for his accommodation
i will need plenty of space to practice
my swordplay i will also need a retinue
to train provide me with your seven best
agents as you call them men of virtue
brave and those with reactions of a
white eagle i do not intend to deliver
my second best on any soul during
training we will train every tuesday and
every thursday we will have a grand
banquet to celebrate our training every
sunday the other days you may use my men
as you see fit good doctor comply with
my requests and you shall have a deal
good sir the night's requests were
approved by the site director of site
06-3 but before he submitted to
containment scp-51
displayed another of his anomalous
abilities the black knight requested to
make a blood pact with dr moreau and his
group of assistants the senior
researcher reluctantly agreed containing
an entity that could pass through walls
would be much easier if
scp-5151 was more cooperative after all
moreau was instructed to slice open his
hand and then accept a handshake from
the night doing so caused an anomalous
marking to form on the doctors and his
researcher's right hands at the same
time when they all held out their hands
and compared the markings they saw that
they were letters that spelled honoris
referred to by foundation researchers as
an instance of
scp-5151-2 this mark caused a notable
burning sensation for dr moreau and his
team as he made his pact with a black
knight some of the research assistants
also reported feelings of dread or
inadequacy as well as an increase in
stress levels however it is unknown
whether
scp-5151-2 causes these directly or if
these are merely side effects of this
permanent mark appearing on the skin in
order to meet the conditions of scp-5151
set for his containment the scp
foundation transferred him to a cell at
site-06-3
any and all electrical devices were
banned from use inside the cell with the
only exception being a microphone to
record audio even the light fixtures
were replaced with oil burning lamps to
give the black knights accommodation a
more medieval feel the site director
also authorized the creation of a
completely new mobile task force
designated as either mtf pi 7 or the
rather appropriate code name the honor
bound knights this unit was made up of
seven of the scp foundation's finest
operatives hand selected specifically
for their proficiency and skill in
hand-to-hand combat each member of the
honor-bound knights wasn't just to be a
skilled combatant but also needed to
create a sense of compatibility and
rapport with
scp-5151 given how much time they would
be spending around the black knight and
multiple mornings throughout the week
every member of the honor bound knights
is instructed to enter the cell of
scp-5151
over the course of the next seven long
hours the mobile task force agents will
spar and train with the black knight
scp-5151 is known to be a formidable
fighter believed to have lived for
centuries which has given him ample time
to hone his own skill with a blade every
sunday evening after they finish their
long hours of sparring a wooden table
and chairs are brought into the cell
each one of the honor bound knights will
then join scp-5151
sitting around the table with him as
they share a medieval meal foundation
personnel will provide the group with
bread pies roasted pig and poultry stews
and soups as well as wine together with
the seven members of the honor bound
nights the black knight will eat drink
and revel until he eventually passes out
then and only then are the operatives of
mobile task force pi seven permitted to
leave their seeds it would seem that the
black knight had exactly what he wanted
most a loyal group of fellow warriors to
spar against and celebrate with however
one member of the unit was noticed to be
acting strangely and was placed under
investigation he was discovered to be in
possession of several highly classified
scp foundation documents as well as
instructions to abduct an unknown scp
held in containment
site-06-3 staff believed this individual
was working on behalf of the chaos
insurgency a known group of interest the
foundation had encountered a number of
anomalous groups over its many long
years of pursuing and containing scps
among them the chaos insurgency is
perhaps the best known formed by former
members of the foundation itself the
insurgency rivals the organization they
once defected from hoping to one day
undermine and destroy it while their
knowledge of scps is more limited they
are far less restricted by rules and
regulations what the insurgency wanted
with the black knight is a mystery but
were willing to guess that they wouldn't
get on well with scp-5151
given his feelings about treachery and
should the chaos insurgency ever get
their way and manage to capture
scp-5151 they might find that capturing
him came with a price paid in blood now
go check out
scp-2273 major alexei bellatrov and
scp-1879 indoor salesman for more
strange beings from the scp foundation